Lisa Marie Presley set to join her
father Elvis and Son Ben in their final
resting place Graceland it's
overwhelming you know a little bit it's
like this is your life and all in one
room
a rep for Lisa Marie's daughter actress
Riley Keough confirmed the burial plans
to E.T the singer-songwriter died
Thursday after going into cardiac arrest
at her LA area home all of the memories
here my favorite you know my my golf
cart key was a big one I have to say I
had my own golf cart that my father gave
me and my the key with a
um tag with my name on it was kind of my
um key to Terror Freedom you know
Mayhem you know it was just that key was
my life at the time of her death Lisa
Marie was still the sole owner of
Elvis's Memphis mansion and its 13 acre
grounds it's absolutely 100 mine always
has been mine Graceland always will be
Lisa Marie sold off most of the Elvis
estate in 2004 but kept the family home
and when it's no longer mine it would be
my children's you know that's that Lisa
has three living kids 33 year old Riley
and 14 year old twin daughters Harper
and Finley her son Benjamin Keough died
by Suicide three years ago he was just
27. Ben's buried next to his grandfather
in Tennessee and Lisa will join the
family plot it's a meditation Garden
beside the house a place filled with
happy memories for the Presleys they
love it there so they just love it and
love the golf carts love the horses and
love eating there and love their family
they love their family they have cousins
there and stuff so they love that
Graceland was of course heavily featured
in baslerman's Elvis biopic Elvis is so
loved and so iconic you feel you feel
responsibility playing any human that
has actually lived but with him it's
it's like it's it's a weight like I
never felt before okay I'd even served
as the site of the press junket where ET
spoke with star Austin Butler inside the
gold record room I know that Priscilla
gave the stamp of approval to this
project so what was that like knowing
that she approves I met her before we
started filming and and uh and then
getting to see her after she'd seen the
film yeah it was so moving to me because
she's also dealt with all the
misconceptions about Elvis's since you
know the day she met him and I was so
nervous when she was going to watch the
film because she knows him better than
anybody and I just thought oh is she
gonna what's she gonna think you know
and so when I when I heard what she what
you felt about it it just was beyond
words
[Music]